when I hit that start streaming button
because if I start talking immediately,
then something at the beginning of the
stream will get cut off.
But it looks like the stream just came
up on Twitch, so we are ready to go.
Welcome to the end of week two.
And let me put up an agenda for today.
So we'll do a brief recap
of Lamport clocks,
which we talked about last time.
Um
then we'll finish our discussion of
vector clocks.
I shouldn't say finish our discussion
because we'll be talking about vector
clocks
quite frequently.
But we'll continue our discussion of
vector clocks.
Um I think we're going to get to
Let's see.
After we do that, we're going to talk
about
executions and properties of executions.
And from there,
I think we'll get to
delivery guarantees, which will include
FIFO delivery,
causal delivery,
and totally ordered delivery.
If we get through all of that, uh if
there's time,
then I'm going to start to answer some
questions
from the start of course survey,
which will be fun.
So I hope we have time for that.
If not, we might have to put it off till
next week. All right, uh let's jump in.
So last time we talked about Lamport
clocks. Uh
what's the relationship between Lamport
clocks and causality?
Well,
the relationship that we wrote down last
time is this.
Uh if A happens before B,
then we know that the Lamport clock of A
is less than the Lamport clock of B.
So, what about the other direction?
If the Lamport clock of A
is less than the Lamport clock of B,
is this true?
We talked about this last time. Somebody
remind me.
No.
So this is in fact not the case, and we
saw an example of that last time.
And we could write down an even simpler
example.
So last time we looked at a kind of a
fancy example with a lot of events, but
we could look at an even simpler one.
So let's just say we have a couple of
machines here, and let's say that we
have Let's say a bunch of internal
events
over here
on this machine. So if we were to give
Lamport clocks to these events, recall
that with Lamport clocks, everybody
starts with uh
their process initialized to zero,
and then you increment on every event.
So this would have a Lamport clock of
one and a Lamport clock of two, um
three, four,
and so on.
So let's say that it happens to be the
case that over here there's a there's a
message send,
and it goes to here.
Well, this one would also have a Lamport
clock of one, this event on machine two,
cuz it's the first event that that uh
that that happens on that process. And
then
of course, as we talked about before,
the Lamport clock gets sent along with
the message under the Lamport clocks
algorithm that we discussed. Message
gets over here. The Lamport clock on
this process is four. Compare four with
one and four wins,
and then increment that by one. So this
gets uh Lamport clock five.
But if we were to look at two events on
here, like say this one
and this one,
what's the what's the happens before
relationship between these two events?
Do they have a happens before
relationship?
Yeah, these events are not related by
the happens before relation. That's
right. So even though
this event over here has a Lamport clock
of four and this one had a Lamport clock
of one, we can't say that this one um
happened later, right? We can't say that
this one happened before this one.
Because Lamport clocks don't give us
enough information to know that. So
it would be nice if we had a way of
assigning logical clocks to events that
does tell us exactly
what happened before what, and that
exists and we talked about it last time.
It's called vector clocks.
You have
both ways of this relationship.
So this is
a two-way implication, which is really
really nice to have.
And we talked last time about the
algorithm for assigning vector clocks to
events. Um so what we didn't have time
to do before is look look at a
example.
So let's go through an example of
assigning vector clocks to events, and
then
uh and then we'll talk about it.
So I'm a little bored of names like M0
and M1 and M2, so let's talk about our
friends
Alice, Bob, and Carol.
Okay, let's put in a bunch of events up
here
and messages.
I think that's enough.
All right. So let's try to remember the
algorithm that we talked about last
time.
Uh so the first step
is that every process is going to keep a
vector
of integers that's going to be
initialized to zero.
And recall from last time that there's
going to be one entry in this vector for
every process that's in the system. So
in this case, there's going to be three
entries.
So everybody's going to keep a vector
initialized to zeros.
And now we can go through and start
assigning vector clock values to all
these events.
So let's look at this first event here
on Carol.
So
it's an event, happens to be a message
send,
and so Carol wants to count it
as an event that's occurred that she
knows about, an event that's occurred on
her process. So what is Carol going to
update her vector clock to? What do you
think?
These entries in this vector clock, by
the way, correspond to Alice, Bob, and
Carol in that order.
That's right. Yeah, so Carol's going to
update her vector clock to
001.
Carol's message gets over here to Bob.
Bob's vector clock is currently at all
zeros.
What is Bob going to do? Well, this
receive is an event.
So, Bob wants to update his own entry in
his vector clock
uh to take note of that event. But also,
this vector clock from Carol got sent
along with the message.
So, what Bob is going to do is
he's going to update his own entry.
So, it's going to be 01, but then he's
also going to take that one from Carol
and combine it with his own entry and
take the maximum of the two.
So, his entry is now going to be 011.
So, what he did was he first incremented
his own position to get 010, and you
could write that in as a sort of
intermediate step if you want to.
And then, he combines
that 010 with Carol's 001 and takes the
pointwise maximum of every entry there
to get this, which is his vector clock,
which is going to be the vector clock
associated with this event.
All right. So, that's what Bob does for
his very first event.
What's next? Uh what's what's going to
be the vector clock for Bob's next
event?
Looks like somebody already put it in
chat.
So, it's going it's going to be 021.
That's right. Yeah, so when we did
Lamport clocks, it was a little
different. We were saying uh
max plus one, and that's because that
that plus one
if you think back to Lamport clocks, the
reason why we had to do a plus one with
Lamport clocks was to count the receive.
So, the receive counts it as an event,
but Bob has already counted his receive,
right? Because that's that's what this
one right here represents.
So, that the receive is getting counted.
That's what this is. Um and that the
fact that this event happened, and then
this one also carries over information
about this other event that happened way
over here.
So, in some sense, you can look at this
vector clock, look at the entries here,
and see, well, Bob knows about a total
of two events at this point. He knows
about the event that just happened on
his own process, and he knows about this
event that that happened over here on
Carol.
Furthermore, he knows that this one
happened on his process, and he knows
that this one happened on Carol's. So,
he knows about one of his own events,
and he knows about one of Carol's
events.
So, we get here.
Bob has incremented his own vector clock
because this is an event. It's a send,
so he wants to increment his own
position, and then that gets sent along.
What is going to be Alice's vector clock
right here for her first event? Somebody
tell me.
Good. Yeah, it's going to be 121.
Why is it 121? Because the one is
because the increment for herself,
right? Because she just received this
message, and that that counts as an
event.
And then the two and the one come from
this message that was sent along, and so
that vector clock gets combined. We take
the pointwise maximum of all the
positions. So, it's 121.
Then there's another event on Alice.
She's going to increment her own
position.
So, this first position turns into two.
The other two positions stay the same.
What happens here on Bob?
For the third event on Bob, what's the
vector clock of that one going to be?
Good. Yep.
031.
You know, normally it takes longer in
the quarter for my markers to start
running out. It feels like this marker
is starting to run out very early in the
quarter.
Luckily, I've got backup markers.
All right. So, that's that event has a
vector clock of 031. The vector clock
tags along with the message. It gets
here to Carol. Carol's current clock was
001.
We're going to combine that with the
031,
and we're going to make sure to count
this event because it's a it's an event,
so it has to get counted.
So, Carol's position gets incremented by
one.
So, we can again put an intermediate
value here if that helps us think about
it.
So, that's the what would happen if
Carol just incremented her own position,
and we're going to combine that with the
031 that came along here.
So, what does Carol's vector clock turn
into here?
Good.
032.
Hopefully, you're starting to get the
idea.
So, I haven't written down the steps of
the algorithm, which we did because we
did that last time, but
I'll try to summarize it again. So, step
one, everybody starts with a vector
initialized to all zeros, and it's the
same length as the number of processes
that they are. So, in this case, we have
three processes, so three entries in the
vector.
Anytime you have an event on your
process, you increment your position in
the vector clock. This means, of course,
that you have to know which your
position is, right? So, that's
information everybody had better agree
that
Alice's position is the first position
here, and Bob is the second, and Carol's
is the third. So, it would be very bad
if the processes were confused about uh
who
was which entry in the vector clock.
Um so, that's an important thing that
these processes have to have agreement
on before you run this algorithm.
And that's something that we can talk
about a little bit more later.
Um so, you increment every time you have
an event,
whether it's a send, receive, or
internal event. I didn't put any
internal events on this one, but um
those would get counted as well
if we had them.
And then, whenever you receive a
message,
you're going to combine the received
vector clock with your current vector
clock by taking the pointwise maximum of
every position.
And so, pointwise maximum just means
that looking at every entry, you take
the maximum of the two numbers that are
at that position.
So, let's go ahead and fill out some
more of these here.
Um so, this one is going to be Carol is
going to be having her third event, so
033.
That's going to get passed along on this
message.
Here we're combining 033 with Alice's
local vector clock.
By now, um Alice's position has been
incremented for this event, so it would
be 321 for the intermediate value if you
want to write that down.
I'm putting these in parentheses to show
that these are like intermediate. This
would typically be done like in the same
step as you're combining with this
value, but I'm writing it down here just
to make this a little bit easier to
reason about. So, 321, take the
pointwise maximum of that and 033, so we
get
333.
Over here, we had 221 that got sent
along here.
Here we are at Bob.
Combine 221 with 031, making sure to
increment Bob's local
entry
in uh or his entry for himself, and we
get
241.
Here's another event on Bob.
So, this one is going to have to be 251.
That gets sent along here.
What's this one going to be? Somebody
tell me. This is the let's see, 1 2 3
fourth event on Carol. What's the vector
clock going to be for the fourth event
on Carol?
Yep, so the first entry will be two.
Combine two with zero, two wins.
For the next entry, five and three, five
wins.
And then for the uh the third entry,
which is Carol's entry, we increment it
to get four, and four is bigger than
one. So, 254. Good.
There's one last event on Carol. This
one gets 255.
That gets sent here.
And here's our very last event
on Alice.
Uh so, somebody tell me what the vector
clock for Alice's last event is.
Good. 455.
By
By the way, I got this um this picture
from Wikipedia.
So, if you
were to look at the
vector clocks article on Wikipedia,
uh there's an image a lot like this, or
at least there used to be.
Okay. So, now that we've gone through
this rather tedious process of assigning
vector clocks to every event here, let's
just go back and look at a couple of
events and um and see
what the vector clocks tell us about
those events.
So,
here's an event
on Bob
right here. I'll call it event A.
Look at event A.
What if I wanted to know which events
happened before event A? Well,
we know from the happens before relation
that everything that occurs before it
on its own process line
happened before A.
So, look at what the clocks of those
events are,
right?
So, this event had a clock of 031, and
this one had a clock of 021, and
this one had a clock of 011.
Well, what else? Well,
there's these events over here on Alice.
So, this one we know happened before A
just by looking at the um the way that
the messages go, right? So, we know this
event
happened before A
because it's a send and A is the
corresponding receive.
And then this one happened before that
one.
So, transitively, that one must have
happened before A.
And then there's this one over here on
Carol, which happened before this one.
So, transitively, that one must have
happened before A.
Okay.
So, I've circled a whole bunch of events
here
that all happened before A.
And we can give a name to all those
events, in fact.
I can circle them all here.
These are the causal
history
of A.
So, what do you notice
about the vector clocks of all of these
events that are in A's causal history?
Is there anything
to take note of about the vector clocks
of those events and how they compare to
A's vector clock?
Very good, yeah. So,
they're all smaller vector clocks than
A.
If we look at the elements of each of
these vectors, they're all going to be
less than or equal to
the value of of A. So, 031, for example,
that's less than 241 in every position,
less than or equal to 241 in every
position.
Similarly, over here, 221 is less than
or equal to 241 in every position. 001,
less than or equal to 241 in every
position.
So, they all have smaller vector clocks.
Likewise,
if we were to go and look at all of the
all of the events
that we know that are causally later
than A,
right? So, this one, for example, we
know is causally later than A.
And then what's causally later than
that? Well, this one
and this one.
Is that it?
I think that might be it. So, these are
the events that are causally later than
A. What do we see when we look at their
vector clocks?
Well, we see that they
have values that are
greater than or equal
to A's vector clock in every entry.
So, I can circle these up as well.
There's not really a name for this set
of events. I guess I could call it the
causal future of A or something like
that.
Um
but um
you get the idea, right? These are
things that we can see happened later
than A according to the happens before
relationship.
Oh, you're right. Somebody just pointed
out that this I missed one. Good.
Didn't even see that one.
That's right. That one counts as later
than A because it happened after this
one here.
And we know that that one happened
before.
Cool. Thanks for catching me on that.
Um so, there's some events that I
haven't circled here
yet.
So, I have one more color left.
Uh so, let's uh let's circle them with
this this other color.
And I apologize I apologize if if you um
if you don't see the difference between
these colors. This is just the colors
that I have available.
So, what's going on here? Well, if you
look at the vector clocks on these
events,
what we what do we have? We have 032 on
this one. Well, that's like
bigger than the vector clock of A in
some places, in particular the last
entry, but smaller in other places. So,
it's neither
smaller nor bigger overall.
Similarly, here, we have an entry that's
bigger in the last position, but smaller
in the first two positions. And then
here,
we have an entry that's
bigger in the first and the third
positions and smaller in the second
position. So, what does that mean?
Well, these events, like say let's say
this one, for example. So,
the entry of 333,
if we try to compare it to 241,
or I should say the vector clock of 333
and I try to compare it to 241,
so, this isn't true. We can't say that
it's less than like that,
and this isn't true, either.
So, what does that mean about these two
events?
That's right. These events are
concurrent.
We say that these events are
concurrent
So, this one and this one. I've I'm kind
of out of room on the picture, so I
don't really have room to add the word,
but
I'll write it down here.
Concurrent or
causally independent.
So, this is great
because now,
if we want to know
about the happens before relationship
between any two events,
we don't have to think about like graphs
and reachability and all that stuff. All
we have to do is compare a bunch of
numbers in a vector.
And it turns out that computers are
really, really good at comparing vectors
of numbers. It's one of the things that
they're best at. So,
vector clocks are great. They're really
widely used in distributed systems, and
they help us precisely reason
about causality.
Any questions about this?
All right.
Good.
So, the next thing I want to talk about,
let's see.
So, way back uh
at some point yesterday,
I briefly mentioned the word protocol.
Um
what did we say a protocol is?
So, I defined it as a set of rules
the processes used to communicate with
each other.
In particular,
it's a set of rules that tell you
what messages that you can send,
and that has to be in terms of what
messages you've received. Okay, so,
here's a really simple protocol.
You could have a protocol where one
machine, well, let's say Alice,
can wake up
and send a message to Bob
that says,
"Hi, how are you?"
And then we can say that our protocol
tells us that Bob must respond with
good, thanks.
So, this is a Lamport diagram that
describes a particular run of that
protocol that I just described.
So,
let's just say that the protocol is in
general any machine at any time can wake
up, send the message hi, how are you?
And when a machine gets that message, it
must respond with good, thanks.
So, that's one run of this protocol.
Here's another run of the protocol.
So, this time
it's exactly the same except this time
Bob was the one who initiated the
protocol.
So, these are both valid runs of that
protocol that I just described.
What about this?
Would you call this a valid run of the
protocol?
Somebody just asked in chat, am am I
using are these examples using UDP?
Well,
I left that unspecified here. So, let's
let's assume that there's no underlying
protocol going on here.
Yeah, so
it's kind of a kind of a weird case,
right? This last case here because
if I'm asking if this is a valid run of
the protocol
has the protocol been violated? Well,
the thing is that these lines go on
indefinitely, right?
So,
it's not necessarily
that the protocol has been violated, we
might have just interrupted the protocol
in the middle.
So, maybe what this diagram actually
looks like is more like this.
So,
in terms of Lamport diagrams
is there any difference between
this
and the first one that I drew over here?
No.
So, distance doesn't mean anything on
these diagrams.
And for that matter
what if it looked like this?
What if Bob sent
his response to Alice way up here?
But for whatever reason, it took a very
long time to get to Alice. Well,
it might seem to Alice as though Bob is
being a little rude. It would be very
awkward, right? Like hi, how are you?
Good, thanks, right? Like it would be
pretty awkward even though Bob tried to
respond promptly. But
there's no difference in terms of
Lamport diagrams between
any of these.
So,
when I talk about a run of a protocol
and I draw one of these things
you could understand that this might
mean different things in terms of
physical clocks, but they all mean the
same thing in terms of logical clocks.
That is with regard to the ordering of
messages, they're the same.
But nevertheless, there
infinitely many Lamport diagrams that
describe correct runs of this protocol.
So, for instance, you could have any
number of back and forth exchanges,
right? You could have
Alice saying hi, how are you? Bob saying
good, thanks. You could have the same
thing again.
Maybe you could have Bob initiate it.
So, there's also no protocol violation
in that picture, right?
I didn't bother to write actually write
out the hi, how are you? Good, thanks on
every line here, but the point is
there's no violation of the protocol in
this picture. So,
there infinitely many different
executions that I could write down
that are
correct executions of this particular
protocol, which doesn't have a name.
Uh
and what you can do though
is you can draw a diagram that
characterizes a violation of the
protocol. So, here's a violation of the
protocol.
If Alice were to just say
good, thanks
without any initial message from Bob,
that one would be a protocol violation.
So,
so it's useful sometimes to think of
violations of some protocol
as being embodied by a diagram. And
that's something that we're going to do
a lot in this class.
If I'm going to talk to you about a
protocol, sometimes it's very hard to
describe the behavior of the protocol
in terms of a picture that describes
what that protocol does because there's
so many different ways to draw a picture
of what the protocol does. So, instead,
sometimes it's much easier to draw a
picture
of what not to do.
So, a diagram can characterize that
protocol violation in some kind of
meaningful way.
So, let's see an example of that.
For something other than just this
simple hi, how are you? Good, thanks
protocol. Let's look at a protocol or
let's look at a property that we really,
really care about
in distributed systems.
So, here's a particular correctness
property
of executions.
Ordered delivery.
Actually, you know what? I'm not going
to call it that, I'm going to call it
FIFO delivery.
If a process
sends
message
M2 after
message M1
any process delivering both
delivers
M1 first.
No, so this is going to be confusing
unless I talk about what this notion of
deliver means.
So, we've we've already talked about
sending and receiving.
And those are pretty intuitive.
So, sending sending a message
is something that a process does.
We'll say something you do.
And receiving
is something that happens to you.
So, you don't control
uh when messages
uh will arrive, right?
They just do or they don't.
But delivering
is distinct from receiving.
So, delivering a message
is something you can do with a message
you receive.
So, a protocol can wait to deliver a
message
until the right time.
It can wait to deliver a received
message until the appropriate time. So,
if you want, if somebody is sending you
messages and you're receiving them,
you can queue up those messages until
you decide it's time to read them.
This is actually a very important
mechanism.
Why might you want to do this? Why might
you want to queue up a message and not
look at it yet?
Any thoughts on that?
Somebody asks, uh can we only deliver
one at a time? Yeah, let's assume for
now that um
message sends and receives and delivers
are just individual messages.
We can talk a little bit later about uh
about sending multiple messages at once,
but let's continue to assume that that
when you receive a message, it's just
one message. When you deliver a message,
it's just one message. Of course, you
could receive or deliver several in a
row.
Yeah, so why would you want to queue up
a received message and not deliver it
immediately? Somebody just uh somebody
suggests, uh maybe you can get further
that would change what you might want to
deliver. Yeah, so that's a good point.
So, in particular,
let's keep this FIFO delivery
definition right here.
A violation of FIFO delivery could look
like this.
So, what's going on here?
Well,
Alice sent two messages
to Bob.
Let's say that this one is M1.
And this one is M2.
That's the order that she sent them in.
But then Bob
is receiving M2 first.
If Bob delivers M2 first, then that
would be a violation of FIFO delivery.
FIFO, by the way, stands for first in,
first out.
So, you can think of FIFO delivery
as establishing
a sort of first in, first out channel
between two processes.
Great question. How does Bob know that
M1 was sent before M2?
Well, let's try to figure it out. What
if we wanted to enforce this property of
FIFO delivery in our distributed system?
Well,
there had better be some way for Bob to
find out
when he gets that M2,
we want Bob to not deliver it
immediately, right? We want him to queue
it up
and wait until he gets the message that
was supposed to come before it.
And then, and only then can he deliver
M2.
So,
how could we establish that? What what
could we do to implement FIFO delivery?
Ah, okay, somebody just asks or somebody
points out we can check the vector
clock.
That's true, and you could get FIFO
delivery that way. But there's actually
an even simpler thing that you can do.
And as a distributed systems
implementer, this is in fact not
something that you're going to have to
do very often.
Does anybody know why it is that you
won't have to worry about this very
often?
So, to be clear, vector clocks would do
the trick.
But if all we we needed was FIFO
delivery,
then vector clocks would actually be
overkill. So, we'll talk more about that
in a little while.
Um
Somebody asks, is it abstracted away
from us? Yeah, in some sense. So,
the reason why you wouldn't have to
worry about this very much in your
day-to-day life as a distributed systems
implementer,
it's because it's already part of TCP.
If you go and look at the TCP spec, uh
you can learn about it. So,
in the spec, they call it ordered
delivery. I I actually don't like that
name. I prefer to call it FIFO delivery
cuz that makes it a little bit more
clear. So,
it's already part of TCP, so you don't
personally have to enforce this property
if you're using TCP. If you're using
UDP, then you would have to if you
wanted it to be true.
Um but if you need this property, if you
need FIFO delivery,
maybe it makes sense to use TCP instead
of using UDP or some other protocol that
doesn't enforce this.
So, for the most part, in your
day-to-day life as a distributed systems
person, um you won't have to worry about
this too much.
So, that's ordered delivery or FIFO
delivery, as I like to call it.
How would one go about
enforcing
FIFO delivery if you did have to enforce
it
for whatever reason? Like let's say that
you aren't using TCP.
How would you go about it? How would you
go about implementing something that
would enforce this?
Or let me put it this way.
For maybe some of you have taken
networking.
Maybe you talked a little bit about the
implementation of TCP.
Uh what does it do to enforce this
property?
Think back to if you took networking,
think back to what you talked about in
that class.
Good. Sequence numbers. Yeah. So, the
usual approach
for implementing FIFO delivery
is something like sequence numbers.
Which works something like this.
So, you're going to tag your messages
with
uh the sender ID
So, in this case, this message would
say, "Hey, I'm from Alice."
And sender's
sequence number.
And
senders increment their sequence
sequence number after sending a message.
So,
that's what happens on the sender's end.
What does the receiver do? Well,
it's going to look at the sequence
number that comes on a message, and it's
going to check
what is what is the sequence number
compared to the previously received
message from that sender.
So, if a received message's sequence
number
is
the sequence number
of the previous message from that sender
plus one
deliver it.
So, what would happen here? Well,
Alice is going to be tagging her
messages with sequence numbers.
So, this one is the first one that she's
sent here.
It's going to get tagged with a sequence
number of one.
This is her second one. It's going to
get tagged with a sequence number of
Whoops. I got that wrong. Um
This one's going to get tagged with a
sequence number of two.
Hopefully, you can see that this one
corresponds to this message and this two
corresponds to this one.
So, message two comes along. It arrives
at Bob. It has a sequence number of two.
Bob's going to look at that sequence
number.
Um
and uh and he's going to say, "Oh, well,
I haven't received any messages from
Alice yet.
So, this can't be right. I shouldn't
deliver this one yet. I'm going to queue
it up for later delivery." Later,
message one is going to come along.
Bob will say, "Okay.
I'll go ahead and deliver this one."
And at that point, he can look back at
the queue and then deliver the previous
message uh
from Alice.
So, that's how sequence numbers work.
Some people are asking really good
questions in chat right now. So, one
person asks, "Are we also worrying about
the message possibly being corrupted?"
Absolutely not. So, that would be a
Byzantine fault and we are not taking
Byzantine faults into account here.
Neither does TCP.
There's another great question. What if
a message gets lost in the middle?
Great. So, yeah, suppose a message gets
lost. What happens then?
Well,
let's say Alice is going along sending
her messages to Bob. So, this one has
sequence number of one. Bob gets it and
delivers it.
There's another one with a sequence
number of two and Bob gets it and
delivers it.
Alice sends message three, but then for
whatever reason that message gets lost.
So, then what happens? Well,
Alice will go and try to send message
four, right?
What happens on Bob's end?
Yeah, exactly. So, Bob's going to buffer
that message, right? He's going to queue
it up for later delivery cuz he probably
figures, "Oh, well, I've already
delivered messages one and two from
Alice.
There must have been a message three
because here's the message tagged with
four.
So, I'm just going to buffer this."
Maybe message five comes along later.
He's got to buffer that one, too.
And so on forever, right?
So, the later messages would get
buffered forever if a message gets lost.
So, this strategy of using sequence
numbers for FIFO delivery
only works well
if you also have what's called reliable
delivery.
So, it turns out TCP has both.
So, reliable delivery is something that
we're going to talk about a little later
in the course after we talk more about
uh fault tolerance.
So, well, just for the sake of argument
though, let's say that you didn't have
reliable delivery. Well, do you have any
other options here? Well,
I mean, one thing that you could do
is if you get these messages from Alice,
like these later ones here, message four
uh message five and so on.
Well, one option is to just
go ahead and deliver them, right?
But then, how would that get you into
trouble?
Yeah, exactly. So, maybe message three
wasn't lost, right? We talked about this
on day one of class.
You don't have any way of knowing if a
message is lost or just delayed for a
really long time. So, what if message
three actually
showed up later, right? Well, then
what's going to happen? Well, then Bob's
going to have to make a choice, right?
He already delivered messages one, two,
four, and five. What is he going to do?
Is he going to drop that message when it
arrives?
Is he going to deliver it even though
it's out of order?
I think you'd have to drop it, right?
Because if you're trying to enforce FIFO
delivery, then it would now be a
violation of FIFO delivery to deliver
message three after messages four and
five. So, you'd have to drop it at this
point.
So,
Bob's faced with a difficult choice
here, right? He can either violate the
property of FIFO delivery
by by delivering the message when he
receives it out of order or he can drop
the message.
And another possibility is that he could
try to do something in between, right?
Like, he could say, "Well, I'll buffer
messages for a while, right? Maybe I'll
have a buffer of a certain fixed size.
And I'll buffer these messages for a
while.
But at some point, the buffer is going
to fill and then I'm going to have to go
ahead and deliver them even though I
don't have all the ones that came
before."
Um
So, in practice, buffers sometimes are
of fixed size and so you have to do
things like that.
So,
in practice,
if you want FIFO delivery, you also need
this other property of reliable
delivery. And we're going to be talking
about this much more uh later in the
course.
Here's another point to make about FIFO.
What if this happens?
Let's say Bob drops all these messages.
Is FIFO delivery being violated in this
picture?
No.
No messages are actually getting
delivered over here.
So, this is another case of that vacuous
truth that we talked about last time.
So, this execution
vacuously
satisfies
the FIFO delivery property.
But this is extremely unsatisfying,
isn't it?
If I were to say, "Yeah, you can
implement a system that that um that
gives you FIFO. Just drop all the
messages, right? FIFO delivery isn't
being violated. Great job. You get an
A."
But that's really unsatisfying. So,
later in the course, we're going to be
talking a little bit more about this.
Okay. We're almost done with our
discussion of of FIFO delivery.
Any other ideas for implementing FIFO
other than sequence numbers?
Can you think of another way
other than using sequence numbers that
we could make sure that our messages are
getting delivered in FIFO order.
Hmm. Yeah, okay. Somebody suggests
timeouts. Could you go into a little bit
more detail about how that would work?
Okay.
So, the suggestion is that we could use
timeouts and that each individual
message would have a timer attached to
it.
So, it sounds to me like what you're
suggesting
is something like this.
Alice sends a message to Bob.
So, I'm not sure exactly what you mean
by the the the message would have a
timer attached to it, right? Because a
timeout would be something that Alice
would would have on her end, right? So,
I'm not sure what it would mean to be
having a timer attached to a message.
But, here's something that Alice could
do.
Alice could wait for Bob to acknowledge
the message.
For every message that Alice sent to
Bob,
Alice could require that Bob sent back
an acknowledgment.
Like this.
So, that would be message one from
Alice. Then, for the next one, once
again,
Bob would need to ack
before Alice uh was able to send her
next message and so on.
So, Alice would be waiting for something
to happen, right? She would be waiting
to get this acknowledgment back from
Bob, meaning, "Okay, I delivered the
message."
And only then would she be able to send
her next one.
Notice that this is kind of nice because
it means that there's no need for Alice
to send the sequence number over to Bob.
Instead,
all she has to do is get back that
acknowledgment before she sends the next
message. It turns out this can give you
FIFO delivery.
But, are there any downsides of doing it
this way?
Great point. Yeah, it's slow. Using
acknowledgments could be slower because
Alice has to sit here and wait for this
message to come back. So, this round
trip has to occur, right? Before Alice
is allowed to send her next message.
Whereas, with this other picture that we
had a second ago,
when Alice was doing sequence numbers,
she can just send these messages and
just keep firing them off without having
to wait for any response from Bob.
So,
this approach of of requiring an ack
from Bob is nice in some ways because it
eliminates the need to send along a
sequence number, but it's also really
slow.
So,
it's not necessarily good if you have a
lot of messages to send.
Yeah, there's this additional issue of
the ack possibly uh getting lost, right?
So, so once again, if the ack gets lost,
then it's as though the message were
never received or or it's as though the
message were never delivered as far as
Alice is concerned.
So, she could sit here forever waiting
for an ack. In practice, she'd probably
have to have a timeout and then send
send the message again. But, then you
get into more difficulties with um
messages being duplicated and so on.
Okay. So, we've talked about a couple of
ways to implement FIFO delivery.
I would like to pause at this point and
do our quiz question for today.
So,
let's set our 10-minute timer and let's
return at 4:34.
And I put two questions on the quiz for
today
um
to make up for the fact that there was
no quiz last time.
Um so, keep in mind you should answer
both, but uh you get credit for writing
down anything at all.
So, I will share the link to this.
All right, let's take our 10-minute
break.
And I'll see you in 10 minutes at
uh 4:34.
All right, let's start up in 1 more
minute.
All right.
It's 4:34. Welcome back.
There's a few fewer responses to the
quiz than usual. I don't know if that's
because fewer people are here or just
because it's hard. So, we'll leave it up
for the rest of class just in case you
need a little bit more time to fill it
out.
Let's uh let's come back to talking
about um
about delivery guarantees.
So,
we just got done talking about FIFO
delivery and we talked about a couple of
ways to implement it.
Let's talk about something that's maybe
a little bit more interesting than FIFO
delivery.
So, a different kind of delivery
guarantee that you might want.
And I think maybe some of you
anticipated it a little bit when you
when you mentioned vector clocks.
So, as usual when talking about
vector clocks,
we're talking about causality.
Uh so, we just got done talking about
FIFO delivery. Now, we're going to be
talking about what's called causal
delivery.
Huh, my handwriting is a little bit
weird there.
Hopefully, you can read it.
My colleague Peter Alvaro is from New
Jersey and he's got a specific way of
pronouncing this word causal. It comes
out like causal when he says it.
And he uses the word quite often.
All right. So, what's causal delivery?
What does that mean? Well,
it's got to be something like, you know,
don't deliver a message until you've
delivered all of the messages that are
in the causal history of that message,
right? So, we just saw a picture a
little while ago when we were
uh talking about vector clocks
of the causal history of a message,
right? So, to bring this back for just a
second,
um or the causal history of an event,
rather.
So,
this would mean that
in case
for whatever reason, let's say that
Carol's message to Bob over here got
delayed, right?
Well, that message had a vector clock
that was established by Carol, right? It
had a vector clock of 001, which means
that it should causally precede this
message over here from Alice.
So, causal delivery should say
that Bob
is not going to deliver this message
from Alice
until he's delivered every message in
its causal history, including this one
back here from Carol. So, let's take a
look at what that would mean.
Uh so, to be precise,
we want to say
if message one's
send
happened before
message two's send,
then
message one's receive
or delivery, rather,
must happen before
message two's delivery.
So, going back to that
picture that we saw a little bit ago
of a violation of FIFO delivery.
Let me ask you a question.
Is this violation of FIFO delivery
also a violation of causal delivery?
Huh, that's an interesting uh point.
Somebody says, "Not yet." Why do you say
not yet?
So, these are messages that have been
Oh, maybe you're saying not yet because
you're saying, "Okay, maybe you're
saying maybe these messages were
received but not yet delivered." Let's
say that these messages already were
delivered.
In that case, would you say that this
violation of FIFO delivery is also a
violation of causal delivery?
Okay, we got a yes.
Why? Why is this a violation of of
causal delivery, also? Well,
if we look back here,
this message, the send of this message
happened before the send of this other
one, right? So, this is M1 in this case
and this is M2. We can tell that this
this message send happened before this
one because they're on the same process
line and with this event first. So that
means that
the delivery of M1 ought to happen first
according to causal delivery. So it
turns out that this violation of FIFO
FIFO delivery is also
a violation of causal delivery.
So we already talked about ways to
enforce FIFO delivery.
It would be really nice if enforcing
FIFO FIFO delivery also took care of
causal delivery for us in general.
Uh but sadly it turns out that it
doesn't. There are cases
uh where something might not be covered
under FIFO delivery
that are nevertheless violations of
causal causal delivery. So let's go back
to our Bob smells example.
So if you recall we had Alice, Bob, and
Carol.
Alice sent a message
to Bob and Carol that said Bob smells.
And then Bob responded
with a message of his own.
And recall that Carol over here was
confused when she got this message.
So what property is being violated here?
Is there a violation of FIFO delivery in
this picture?
What do you think?
So if you need a reminder of the
definition of FIFO delivery, here it is.
So FIFO delivery says
if a process sends message M2 after M1,
any process delivering both
delivers M1 first.
So does it look like a violation of FIFO
delivery is happening in this picture
here? This is kind of a subtle question,
so take a minute to think about it.
Yeah, it turns out the answer is no.
So why not? Well,
think about what FIFO delivery says.
FIFO delivery is talking about two
messages that are being sent by the same
process. A particular process sends
message M2 after message M1.
And then there's the same process that
is supposed to deliver both.
And it's supposed to deliver them in the
order sent. So it has to do with two
messages being sent by the same process
and being delivered by the same process.
But that's not what's going on here.
If you just look at this picture,
there isn't any process in this picture
that receives two messages from the same
originating process.
So Alice is sending her message that
gets to Bob, right?
Bob is sending uh her message that gets
to Bob and Carol. Bob is sending his
message that gets to Alice and Carol.
But there's no place where a particular
person is sending two messages
to the same receiving process.
So this is not a violation of FIFO
delivery in fact.
But it is a violation of causal
delivery.
So what does this mean? Well,
we already talked about how FIFO
delivery is already given to us in some
sense for free
by protocols like TCP. So if we're
implementing our distributed systems on
top of an underlying protocol like TCP,
we're in pretty good shape as far as
FIFO delivery is is concerned.
But sadly, you can have violations of
causal delivery like this one
that aren't violations of FIFO delivery.
So sadly, TCP does not rule out
situations like this.
A guarantee of FIFO delivery by itself
will not prevent this problem.
This violation of causal delivery.
All the interesting violations of causal
delivery like this one
require three or more processes to
demonstrate.
So let's look really closely at this and
make sure we understand why it's a
violation of causal delivery. Well,
here's where Alice's message was sent,
right? It's it got sent back here.
So this is M1. And really both of these
messages from Alice are M1.
They're both the same message, so we
call them both M1.
Likewise with Bob, both of these
messages are M2.
So over here on Carol,
M2 arrives first followed by M1.
But M2's send back here, if you look at
the causal history
of M2's send,
it contains
the send of M1 back here.
So M1 send happened before M2 send.
So if we wanted causal delivery, it had
better be the case
that M1's delivery happens before M2's
delivery. And so if these messages are
getting delivered here in this order,
causal delivery is being violated.
Uh great question. Somebody asked, so
FIFO delivery is a subset of causal
delivery. That's right. Yeah, so if
you're guaranteeing FIFO delivery,
you're you're ruling out some of the
violations of causal delivery.
But not all of them.
We're getting close to the end for
today.
Um but I've talked about so far I've
talked about two different
correctness properties of executions. So
let me put that up again.
So we talked about FIFO delivery
and causal delivery.
We also talked about a way to enforce
FIFO delivery. We talked about sequence
numbers and we talked about
acknowledgements. So those are ways to
enforce FIFO delivery.
We have not yet talked about how to
enforce causal delivery, but we did talk
about vector clocks. And so I'll give
you a big hint, enforcing causal
delivery is going to involve vector
clocks.
And I imagine that if you think about it
a little bit, you can imagine how. We're
not going to have time yet today to talk
about how you implement causal delivery
using vector clocks. We'll talk about
that next time.
Uh but if you want to, you can think
about it a little bit on your own.
There's one more correctness property
that you might want
that I want to mention here.
It's called totally ordered delivery.
So here's the definition of totally
ordered delivery.
By the way, this isn't you should not
think of this as being an exhaustive
list
of correctness properties of executions.
These are just three particular
properties that uh
are going to be particularly relevant to
us.
Okay, back to totally ordered delivery.
This says
if a process
delivers
M1
and then
M2,
then
all
processes
delivering both M1 and M2
deliver M1 first.
What would it look like to violate
totally ordered delivery?
So here's an example.
This one's going to involve four
processes.
So, let's say that this process sends
a message
to these two.
We could call this one M1.
And let's say that this process sends a
message to these two.
We could call it M2.
So, what's going on here?
And let's say that these messages are
being delivered.
I suppose I should give names to these
processes also just to make it a little
bit easier.
So, P1 sent a message to P2 and P3.
P2 got the messages and and and P4 also
sent a message to P2 and P3.
P2 got got M1 first and M2 second.
P3 got M2 first and M1 second.
So, in this case, the processes are
delivering the messages in an order that
disagree.
So, this is what's called a violation of
totally ordered delivery.
When would this come up in real life?
Well, I'll give you a brief example. So,
what if P1 and P4 are
clients that are interacting with a
database?
Let's say it's a key-value store.
And there's two replicas of this of this
key-value store.
So, here's a little database picture for
you.
And maybe
message one and message two are doing
writing to some key in the key-value
store.
And maybe they're writing different
values of the key. So, maybe this client
over here is trying to write
a value of one for X, and maybe this
client over here is trying to write a
value of two.
What happens? Well,
this replica is going to get the right
of
of um of one for X first.
Then it's going to get the right of two.
So, at the end of this uh
um execution,
this replica will think that X is two.
Meanwhile, this one over here got this
right second, so this one will think
that X is one.
So, now the replicas disagree.
This is something that can come up
if you lack totally ordered delivery.
All right, we only have 3 minutes left.
I think that's probably about enough
material for today.
So, just to recap, we talked about three
of these correctness properties of
executions.
Um we talked about FIFO delivery and we
talked about some ways to enforce it.
And then we talked about causal
delivery, and we didn't talk about a way
to enforce it yet, but we sort of hinted
at the idea that vector clocks would be
important. And so, we'll talk more about
that next time.
And then we talked about totally ordered
delivery and we looked at this as
example of a violation of totally
ordered delivery.
And we haven't at all talked about how
to
uh how to enforce totally ordered
delivery.
Turns out that's a hard problem. So,
that's something we're going to have to
come back to.
I want to spend the last two minutes
that we have doing something a little
bit more fun,
uh which is some of the answering some
of the questions that folks asked
uh in the start of course survey.
So, let's flip to that.
All right, so the last question on the
start of course survey was
any questions for me
about anything?
And so, we got a variety of questions,
and I just want to look at this first
one here. So, the question was, I would
just like to know the applications of
distributed systems in the real world.
What kinds of projects are related to
this field? What kinds of jobs are there
for this field?
So,
uh let me tell you a couple of things.
So, uh one is that in in this class
we've typically had a lot of external
guest speakers from uh either from
people who work in industry and and work
with distributed systems, uh or
sometimes we have a panel of recent UCSC
grads who talk about their experiences.
And these are usually people who've
taken the course and are talking about
what they're doing in their jobs now.
I want I really really want to fit in
something like this in this course this
quarter. Unfortunately, the
Tuesday-Thursday schedule makes it tough
because we only have 20 rather than 30
lectures. So, it's unfortunately, that
makes it really hard to give up a
lecture uh for for a guest speaker.
But I'm trying my best. So, right now I
have one slot set aside for a guest
speaker and um it's either going to be a
panel of recent grads who are going to
come and tell you about what they do,
or it's going to be somebody uh
from industry who's not necessarily UCSC
grad. Um so, I'm looking forward to
that. But just in general, you know, I
hope that stuff like this picture and
this example of um
uh replicated database and I hope that
the stuff that we talked about on day
one of class and so on gave you a little
bit of insight into the answer for this
question. Um but the short answer what
is this is deeply relevant to practice
and
graduates who know about this stuff are
very much in demand. Uh in fact, I've
asked a a friend uh
to pass along some job postings that I
can share with you all soon.
And I hope that this uh the second
question here is, how difficult will
this course be and how relevant will
this information be? So,
I mean, I think the answer to both of
those are, well, I think it is going to
be fairly challenging. I think this
course is is is going to present a
challenge to many of you, but I think
that it's going to be worth it.
And I keep hearing from people who have
graduated and say that this course
helped them a lot. In fact, I keep
meaning to put up some testimonials that
I've received on the course webpage.
Maybe I'll do that this weekend.
You know, I thought this was going to be
more fun because there's some fun
questions further down in here, but um
the first two questions were kind of
heavy.
All right, maybe next time we're going
to get to the little bit further down
the list and we'll be able to get to
some of the more fun questions that that
I know some of you submitted. Um but
we're out of time for today, so let's
wrap up.
Thank you, and remember uh that the
first of all that the first assignment
is due tomorrow at midnight, and that
you need to be sure to join a team. So,
if you haven't done so yet, be sure to
join a team, and uh Patrick asked me to
point out that the form for team
sign-ups is editable. So, in case you
made a mistake, uh you can edit the
form. Uh so, be sure to do both of those
things, finish assignment one and sign
up for your team by tomorrow.
Uh we're over time, so let's wrap up for
today,
and I'll see you next time.